hey guys I'm off the grid for August but
my buddy Patrick Bet David is making
sense as he usually does thank you for
handling a little of the nonsense pbd
while I am God I have a reputation to
ask tough questions and piss some people
like you
offering dead people want me to stand up
for you oh trust me we are standing up
for the morning let's see you better get
back to that list because we're going to
clear some people's names today my
question for you is my question for you
is how is it
that in the last 50 years
we don't have a single candidate
everybody has their own hey John F K was
a Playboy with Marilyn Monroe Trump
Karen McDougall Stormy Daniels you know
George Bush linked to 9 11 and weapons
of mass destruction Bill Clinton linked
to Arkansas women all this others
everybody has a reputation how is it
that the reputation that follows them is
people close to them die
why is that a story that people many
people believe in why are the clintons
in their 70s yet if I you don't think I
can make a list of other people who are
70 something years old and say this
person
hold on how come they haven't done that
with bush he's on the same same I have
no freaking idea why it happened but so
are you saying so you agree with what
I'm saying that with Reagan so how come
down but none that would care what are
you making about these men and women who
uses so many people close to them die
how is it so many people close to
everybody dies are you suggesting okay
I'm asking the questions you're asking a
bizarre question exactly did people stop
did people die no what pisses me off I'm
gonna say this again because you
apparently you're not listening to me
you read a list of people off an obscure
website that that that of conspiracy
theory taking a Venn diagram of everyone
that ever worked in the orbit of someone
who served in public life for 50 years
and you listed them including people in
the military including strangers you
could not pull out of and you are
implying that there's something to say
here let me finish my thoughts let me
finish my thoughts please do so because
I got another let me finish my thoughts
on here for you you're implying both
with the question and with the website
the website says it
explicitlyn let me finish go ahead
you're implying that something's done
go for it you are implying that
something nefarious is a foot both with
the question and with the list
Hillary Clinton she's a big girl I'm a
big boy you're a big boy the people that
you just listed they're all listen to me
no these are obscure people that you
could not pull out a great politician
buddy wait a whole life fantastic you
know what you are you are you are the
classical you list someone's name are
you gonna go back everybody
you know that ad hominem attack on me
yeah he's gonna somehow clear that
person's name there's anybody at this
table that's a bigger balloon I tell you
oh yeah you you just listed some
stranger
things
you're reading something good for you
reading a a concern
Ed
some people some people
saying to you Wikipedia you Wikipedia
conspiracy website you want it no no no
you want to take a run at me bring it
all day yesterday
conspiracy theory right at the top where
can I do a mic I can drop conspiracy
right at the top what's the point with
that the point is
that people don't have this conspiracy
theory how come Reagan doesn't have this
conspiracy theory oh wait a minute
oh wow really why do they though some of
the stereotypes are true like you have
some reputation it's true some of it
some of the stuff they say about other
people it's not a stereotype that's a
made-up story about strangers how come
others don't have that made-up story
people have it all the time look at the
internet give me another body count with
another president or candidate do you
really think that something do me a
favor do you really think Barack Obama
body count do you really think oh you
want to go why don't you go to Barack
Obama not born in this country by the
way where was that podcast did you guys
do that one no that's never anything oh
why oh come on so people say it
there's there's a Wikipedia thing on it
huh these people are strangers that you
just read a list of and I think out of
deference to them
settle down no no no you're pretty hard
to take the angle you did listen to me
you're talking to us yeah oh okay you
should cut that list out of those sure
we can still have the argument you and I
are big boys cut that list I'm not going
to be cutting that list